l tutti ragazzi e benvenuti questo video
sono fa vj e siamo ritornati su ogni
[ __ ] volta devo dire che anche che da
un secolo che non lo faccio perché aver
boltro tra l'altro cioè poltrone i primi
livelli non l'ho mai visto provo a
vincere subito ragazze anche se dubito
di riuscire
mica è passato tanto così niente non ce
la farò mai aprendo la vita abbiate oa
chi è che l'ultimo ragazzi poi cambio
giusto per capire se sono io giorno ma
quanto è bello lei molto più di quanto
pensassi il prossimo il challenge idb
halloween che io dove sperimenta devo
beccare la bottiglia per vincere a
forchia pacifica l'ho presa in pieno
proprio dai ragazzi dalla mia io la mira
siamo una cosa succede proprio andiamo a
bere insieme senza guardare anche alla
fragile proprio no vabbè dai devo
riuscire a vincere senza farmi uccidere
da gli arpioni ma se facendo ragazzi
scrive è diventato un porco all'impresa
fi ma non sta inglobando niente 6 gruppo
non ha o
[Musica]
ce l'ha con questa o ragazzi avete fatte
sarà sexy che ti devo dire non uscire si
beh più o meno piano il mio culo
assodato
mi chiamo stivato ragazze il mio culo è
il numero è il bersaglio number one ecco
non dovevo dire basta cosa ditemi voi se
per colpa del mio culo devo rimanere
cosa ecco i ragazzi in plus è veramente
impossibile
cos'è ho vinto sì che mossa da ninja era
questa va bene così bmx marca un loft
sta roba vado con nonno ciak che lui che
lui ci sa fare sulle bmx verona perfetto
e ha capito che ma ci si fanno delle
rampe il suo livello no vero eccola
invece date facendo sì ho vinto bello ho
letto sto andando o mio dio tuffo della
fede proprio caso e fede sia
ghigliottina in qualche lingua mi
chiedevo ma veramente nostra ma perché
ci sono anche i bambini alla
ghigliottina nell'europa per bambini ei
vecchi 18 padova il posto a hold ok e
non l'ho capita sta roba
boom
sono male è stato bello rops in questo
mi sembra carica in spagnolo
il robot mi sbaglio mi mancavano
bellissimo ai vai vai vai vai ora è
perfetto nel pube
mio dio ragazzi ecco che perché non sono
morto e già è già un vantaggio che stai
facendo ed in queste perché sei [ __ ]
nel cervello se non ci sarebbero se i
problemi
niente ecco bravo non è se neanche
rientrare nel nei canonici abbiate
pazienza quindi dovrebbe o che sta
durando mezz'ora sto di aver prefetto
cioè non lo sa che col g fonemica sta
roba è bellissimo che bello capace
l'anguria nel bar ove non voglio saperlo
vai vai vai vai vai vai madonna
resta ancora la vedo malissimo happy
meals è diventato così ormai diventato
gippone simulator con uno ciak questo da
o mio dio sto andando regale vabbè
pazienza
ok non vivo vivo questo guidate ma
perché io conosco gente che guida coi
piedi fuori dal parabrezza sono un
fenomeno a guida perché a milano la
patente tipo subito non mia moglie e mio
padre sono andati o mio dio sa fa col
papa che brutta cosa e narrava fermi un
attimo ragazzi che potrebbe essere una
cosa è successo papà nonno cia che il
padre viaggi non sapevo neanche cosa
guarda è pioniere
non lo so che cosa è successo poi ci
sono delle anatre che sono le più belle
che abbia mai visto credi che quella mia
moglie jubran cosa occorre via via via
via via via via via via via che dovrebbe
tornare mi sono fatto male però pazienza
di skate were waiting for one si vede
chi è il vero uomo amico mio tu hai una
spalla del delle tane sei morto io no
due non sono neanche troppo bello giorno
gli skybox hard bravo questa amico mi ha
battuto chi credi di giocare scrive a me
forse un po difficile possibilità 0,0
schumi si sa con chi stai parlando tu
non hai dai lardo minali si no
e di questo è presente che cos'è questo
è un tuo amico questo lo conosci
va be killed è morta era già tanto ormai
non non ce lo sappiamo che sono tra pro
fare un cenere che è sta roba
ho preso mentre gli hanno fatto un cazzo
del web su in pizza
cos'è sta roba renault robson pisanò
vabbè dai seriamente devo attaccarmi a
delle pizze per fare un rock swing d
italia bello bello bravo eddy mi chiama
è ispirato questa cosa l'ho preso l'ho
presa e l'ho presa ma all'inizio quelle
imposte impossibile sembrava affatto sto
livello un obeso non capito ma eccoci ce
l'abbiamo fatta è stato tragico trash
track cosa strana ma non devo
raccogliere le cose bello una caduta una
paziente 5 10 secondi per cosa
immondizia caso perché bisognerebbe
buttare dell'insalata
così grazie comunque slot rojas e va beh
la città è pulita oggi grazie a parigi
assassins fall la caduta dell assassino
bene l'ho preso ciò fa eco la linea il
culo tutta perfetto mie mm veri e tv
entrato nel deretano fantastico io posso
colpire la gente col mio culo vittoria
ti giuro che se ti muovi ti infilzo brad
cioè su happy wheels ma veramente hanno
fatto in brand su è più il nuovo geniale
hai vinto a parte che sembra due tette
tester nov la inserimento finissima è un
fatto veramente aim brad su rep
non era il geniale non rai ai fantasmi
perché fatti scazzi e fantastiche l'ho
fatta dopo
dov'è il tostapane che non lo trovo dai
che dovuto stare sta roba
si no ucciso un vaso che bella banana
ragazzi nella banana più bella che abbia
mai visto basta
victor è perfetto tu sai che mi sta
respingendo non riesco mi fa schifo se
ho vinto agli emmy godzilla perché certo
non è di travestito no è ben più
godzilla giorno ascoltano non sono è di
travestito sono godzilla faccio paura
sono morti euro ok ho appena fatto
crollare una torre ma non fa niente è
una donna peso bellissime le persone sto
livello cazzo quella è la mia speciale
coda letale non penserete mica che sono
è di travestito non amava questo non
sono tre cose ho vinto bellissimo orphan
cose stormi anno abbreviato il nome
l'hanno messo in un titolo suicidio cosa
fai you say pregando cosa preghi vinco
io
vince la gamba cioè devo passare su dei
dei tronchi praticamente mica manuale
che non passa sulla fiesta non fa ridere
un cazzo quindi senza abbraccio
all'altro perse non si sa come ho vinto
io ho vinto e d'accordo ragazzi facciamo
a che livello dedicato a me perché non
ne facciano un botto di tempo fa vince
la bella verdetto al mio piacere fa vige
la riscossa fa vigeva vendetta noi io
che vogliamo ucciderti e questo solo
solo perché tu sei uccisi in tantissimi
si missy missimi intimissimi amico mio
che cosa fumi da mattina lo chiedo
perché non è normale una capra vabbè dai
sono punti di vista
sono vivo altro libro perfetto il bello
è questo livello e contro luke poi sto
andando con duke è bellissimo non ha
senso va bene e ci sono bravo io nel
tiro a segno
bravo vai vai vai vai andando come
faccio a battere un meteorite me lo
spiegate
non si può fare non si può superare un
meteorite grazie lo apprezzo ma vj quiz
easy è una roba del flusso video fa
vigente in inglese renderà ma perché in
inglese ma chi cazzo lo vede in inglese
non importa forte fa vigeva ben sono
caduto a caso ho vinto a caldo o al
dhafra vj 11 anni
siete dei geni gong fa vj hem del gf gf
che cazzo il grande fratello non un
fratello sono figlio unico a norcia voce
rho il fratello boati snel mo favi gemma
mio dio ma come se iscrivendomi con ma
per chi è chino perché io vorrei capire
per cosa ti è passato nel cervello
quando hai fatto trovato dio ci fa bj
cavalca lo snake evocava premi spazio
poi ok ad evocare chiara un serpente che
bello perché ama perché schiaffi go però
sembra finto sono dopo a serpenti un
fenomeno da quattro ragazzi stato
istruttivo soprattutto concluso qui
l'episodio di ogni volta che gioco è
primis mi sento più intelligente subito
dopo il video è piaciuto commons aveva
lasciato momento mi piace anche
appoggiati facebook e camerali la tratta
descrizione sicuri city si è felici
delle ragazze
[Musica]